hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting position that occurred uh
from round four of this year's superbed
rapid tournament it is a Magnus Carlsen
versus Maxima Shiela grav and it is the
position that arises is something that
is referred to as a cursed win now the
position you will see after a few moves
have been made uh magnets will have a
completely winning position but it will
require him more than 50 Moves In order
to actually win the game now of course
he cannot win because if Maxine plays
perfectly the 50 move rule will apply
and for those of you who perhaps do not
know what a 50 move rule is if no piece
has been captured and no Pawn has been
pushed for 50 moves then the the game is
proclaimed a draw uh so that this is why
this is considered a curse to win
because it's it's winning by force uh
however you cannot win because it will
require you for more than 50 moves to
actually win this now the thing that is
most interesting here is the reason why
the 50 move rule was introduced used in
the first place and the reason is as
they say
um uh you know on the almighty internet
the purpose of this rule is to prevent a
player with no chance of winning from
obstinately continuing to play
indefinitely Or seeking to win by tiring
the opponent now of course this means
that if you're playing a classical game
and the position is a dead draw and
let's say you're
15 years old or maybe 20 years old and
you're playing against uh maybe a 90
year old gentleman uh you know and you
decide okay we're gonna play this for
five more hours uh chances are you will
win that game because you will Tire him
out or her uh but um here it is it's no
such case because here it's objectively
winning by force and here uh the
position that we are going to discuss
will be winning by forcing 83 moves and
we're gonna show the win uh so I'm very
interested in what you guys think about
this is is this some sort of a rule that
should be abolished is it a rule that
only needs Improvement what uh is there
an improvement that could be made uh so
I'm very interested in what you guys
think about all of this so let's check
out and see what happened Magnus has the
white pieces and he opens with D4 and
also a quick announcement I realized uh
some of you were saying in the comments
on a couple of my previous videos uh
that if you switch to portrait mode
you can and see the entire screen this
is only a case if you are an iPhone user
there's been some sort of an update on
the iPhone YouTube app where once the
video starts it assumes The Fill
automatically so as I'm not using the
native resolution that's pretty much a
native to everyone's uh monitor it's uh
1920 by by 180p I'm using a different
one it's a 1920 by 1200 which is weird
but a long long time ago when I started
YouTube I had monitors that were 1900 by
by 1200 so I I started using that and it
just stuck so if iPhone doesn't change
this I will I will fix it at some point
but even if I fixed it now or the
previous 3000 videos that I've made will
all be in messed up resolution but even
if you're an iPhone user and your video
starts with zoom to fill you can just
you know pinch it down and it will
improve the uh
the video so you can see the entire
screen so it's a it's a very quick fix
but I will I will tend to it at some
point maybe maybe even tomorrow uh you
know just Just for future videos uh but
okay let's continue the game Magnus
opens with the D4 we have Pawn to D5 by
Maxine Bishop to F4 Magnus goes 14 uh
for the so-called accelerated London
system uh Knight to F6 and Ponte E3 we
have Pawn to C5 and now Pawn to C3 uh
Knights the C6 and now Knight to D2 We
have pawned the E6 and Knight G2 F3 at
night stage five Maxim goes after
magnus's Bishop on F4 we have Bishop to
G5 and F6 continuing to chase the bishop
Bishop to H4 and now G6 now this has all
been played before of course you don't
want any nasty discoveries on that night
so it should be defended Pawn to H3 and
now C captures on d4c captures Bishop to
D6 and Bishop to D3 we have castles and
now the position has been reached before
it's been played between
in the Tata steel Masters Tournament of
2021 uh where uh where Ponte A3 was
played by alireza but here Magnus just
castles and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game
uh so Bishop to D7 Rook to E1 we have
Queen to B6 and A3 inviting Maxim to
capture the pawn on B2 and it could be
that the opponent B2 can be captured but
um it's a rapid game of course you don't
want to capture uh upon Magnus is
offering just like that so Knights the
G7 uh and now Pawn to B4 of course
Magnus defense we have Knight to F5
going after the bishop and now Bishop
captures on F5 we have e captures on F5
and now Knight to B3 uh Knight to E7 we
have Knight to C5 this is not a
beautiful Monster Knight there's very
little you can do against it uh Rook 8
and d8 and now Rook the C1 with Bishop
the C8 and now Queen to B3 nicely
putting the queen on this diagonal uh we
have King to G7 getting out of the way
and just Knight the H2 we have G5 Knight
to a for now attacking the queen first
queen to B5 and now only now Bishop to
G3 and now uh there's very little to
think about here you wanna ruin magnus's
Pawn structure captures captures and
queen back to D7 we have rooked the C2
Magnus prepares to double up on the C
file Queen to D6 and now just a first
Knight to F1 of course you defend the G3
Pawn the queen would gobble it up B6 and
only now Knights the C3 with Bishop to
D7 and now Pawn to B5 since you are not
allowing the Knight to jump in Pawn to
B5 we have Rook to C8 and The Rook e to
C1 Magnus is now ready to trade down
Rooks along the C file Rook to C7 Maxim
also prepares to double up on the C file
Knight to E2 and Rook after C8 we have
captors captures The Rook captures on C7
Queen captures and now Knight the D2
yeah we have Bishop date King F2
uh the king is uh an excellent Defender
here now the G3 Pawn is defended so the
Knight I need you can move Queen to C3
uh not a bishop to F7 Queen to C3 and
now Queen to D7 we have Pawn to A4 uh
defending on B5 and now Queen to C8
offering a queen trade and Magnus says
all right we've done everything we can
here with our active Queen let's trade
Queen characters Knight captures and now
Knight to C1 now it's two knights
against the bishop and Knight and let's
see uh who's better here black should be
better because the play is on both sides
of the board and Maxime does have a
bishop but it's rapid chess uh you have
to play very quick moves with Knight the
A2 Bishop T6 Knights the B4 and now
Knights the E7 as both of them have
played this end game out
um very very precise uh uh the end
result should be a draw but it's not or
rather it shouldn't be or rather you
know you guys will decide on that King
37 King he won King D6 King to B2 Bishop
C8 King to C2 Bishop to D7 Knights to D3
Bishop to E6 and King to B3 now the King
has
gotten all the way to the queen side
Knight the C8 Knight to B4 with uh 97
Knights to D3 Knights the back the C8
and finally Pawn to A5 you have to push
Pawn otherwise it's just gonna be a draw
uh we have King to C7 Knight to B5 for
Bishop B captures an A4 five uh Knight
A6 and King to D6 with Knight to C5
Knight to B6 and not Knight to B7 with
check King to C7 and Knight captures an
A5 with H6 King to B4 and now Bishop to
D7 with uh King to C5 Bishop to E6 and
now Knights the C6 so
uh going after that A7 Pawn Knight the
D7 checking to B4 and pawn to A6 now of
course you can't capture because King
captures Knight so Knights the E7 and
now captures mb5 we have Knight captures
on B5 and King to d8 we have uh Knight
the C6 with the check King to C8 King to
A5 and knights the f8 so the material is
equal of course the game should be a
draw not before we ignite the G6 Knight
to C3 and Ponta F4 yeah very nicely done
by Maxim G captures G captures and now
Knight B captors on D5 Magnus grabs a
pawn there F captures on E3 now Knight
captures on E3 we have Pawn to F5 and
Ponta D5 Magnus starts advancing his
pass Pawn F4 and now Knights the C4 with
F3 D captures an E6 F captures on G2 and
92 of course stopping promotion with the
King 38 King to B4 Knights the F4 uh of
course trying to get the Knight away
from the defense of the G1 Square so you
can promote your onto a queen tonight
the G1 King E7 and King to C3 with Pawn
to H5 Knights the D2 and now King
captures an E6 with King D4 H4 uh Knight
D to F3 and Knight captures on H3 Magnus
uh now has a chance to win material uh
but of course it is not enough to
actually win the game or or maybe it
should be Knight captures on H3 G1 Queen
Knight F characters and G1 and now King
to D6 and this is the position that we
are going to discuss uh this is move ad
uh and uh magnus's position is
completely winning you can check it on
the on the table bases yourselves but
I've put it um yeah in the table base
and it says that white has a force to
win in 83 moves and this is what I was
talking about as the 50 move rule has
been introduced in order to prevent the
player from playing a drawn uh end game
indefinitely uh this is not a drone
engine this is a completely winning end
game so that's why
I was very very interested by that and
this is what it's no what is known as a
cursed win or a cursed uh position so
I'm just gonna show it Magna starts with
Knight to F3 and now uh here I'm just
gonna show you the best defense by black
and how white wins against best defense
and that is King to C6 uh King to C4 and
now you will have to bring the black
king all the way uh to the to the upper
corner to pull off this Checkmate uh
because once you move the Knight the
pawn will just start marching forward
and everyone knows that if there are no
pawns if it's only King in two Knights
versus the king then it's a draw but if
black has a pawn then it can be winning
so here Knight the uh King the sixth
Knight the D4 King to E5 you will uh uh
well you will basically play uh very
very uh fancy moves to to drive the
blacking all the way up to the h8 square
but it's not going to be easy so here
you will have to perform a series of
very very precise moves uh go after the
king I'm just gonna fast forward it so
you you guys uh I mean it's a lot of
moves but uh just to show you uh the
technique that will be used okay now you
uh got the blacking where you want him
uh you will cut him off completely uh
let's uh see it one more time uh there
we go check uh King goes after the black
king and now you start uh basically you
cut off the uh black king from escaping
so now these scores are covered of
course uh the blacking will try to uh
not to go up the board but the C1 square
is also covered so you can see that the
king and Knight do a fine job of forcing
the black king to go uh right for the
moment so here Knight C1 King D1 of
course the black king doesn't want to go
and now Knights the C3 controls the D1
Square so we have to time it perfectly
first control the C1 Square then control
the D1 Square then control the E1 square
and so on and so on and push the black
king up the board so this is how you do
it uh here you can't capture the Knight
it's uh it's a very tricky technique
that you would have to use because if
you capture then King to F2 and after
King to H1 you will of course very very
easily Checkmate to the black king with
Knight to the G3 checkmate
uh so that's the problem so you would
have to go up the board and now uh once
you start going up the board then you
start bringing the Knight now the two
knights are covering the these squares
uh the king is covering these squares so
the black king has to go up the board so
it's uh you know goes up the board goes
up the board uh and now after a few
precise moves you also use the the exact
same technique to completely box the uh
black king in and now you start to bring
your uh final Knight into the attack
Knight G4 King h8 Knight here you will
push the pawn but it doesn't matter just
uh Knight to F4 and after the queen is
promoted you will deliver a nice Knight
to G6 Checkmate so this is uh how you do
it if perfectly played by black so if
black defends perfectly this is how you
win and that's uh uh what I wanted to
discuss here is the is the is the 50
move rule really something that should
be applied here as it was invented to
prevent someone from just dragging on
the game and here you've seen that the
the position is objective completely
winning for white but okay Knight to F3
was played King E6 in the the game
continued King C5 King D7 and very
quickly Magnus decided to gobble up that
pawn because of course it would take him
way way too many moves to actually win
this uh especially with the both of them
being uh solo on the clocking of 695 and
King characters and G5 and he was in
this position that the uh players uh
well were forced into a draw uh as now
it's draw by insufficient material
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I'm very interesting uh very
interested that uh think what we're very
interested to hear what you guys think
about
this idea should it be should the 50
move rule be abolished should it be
improved uh can you think of any
Improvement that could be implemented uh
maybe just for Rapid chess maybe for
Blitz chess maybe for online chess uh
you know it's definitely something to be
discussed uh so yeah there we have it
maybe something to think about I would
like to thank David Kimura AMD recent
Enthusiast group golfsoftware.com
Pauline and Gary Shaw for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament and everything else
that happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and remember
for now if you're using an iPhone to
watch this you know just uh zoom zoom
zoom out a little bit and everything
will be fine uh see you soon